I think we've got a lot of scientists
working in the United States,
certainly already.
Um,
would we like to have more funding?
Of course everybody wants more funding
for their particular area.
You know,
if I were in the theater,
I'd been in demand more government
funding for,
you know,
theater productions.
Um,
so yeah,
more money would be nice.
But I think the real role that the
president can play in this broader kind
of theme of Science Literacy is in
education using the presidency as a
bully pulpit to get out the message that
science is important.
It's not just something that's done by
the scientists,
for the scientists,
it's done by the scientists who were
citizens for everybody else in the
country and it with the collaboration of
everybody else in the country because at
least in terms of a government supported
science,
it's paid for by the rest of the
country.
So,
you know,
I think scientists have a role to play
as well.
I think scientists should perhaps make
more of an effort to communicate with
the public at large about the work
they're doing and the implications and
why it's important.
You know,
it's,
it's perhaps easier to ask for more
money than it is to explain to people
who don't have a scientific background
why you need more money.
But I think the latter is at least as
important.
And you know,
it's these days,
in my opinion,
part of being a scientist,
but responsible somehow.